عمليات البحث تتسع في درنا مع تمكن فرق
الانقاذ لاول مره من دخول الجزء الشرقي من
المدينه الامم المتحده تطلق نداء للاغاثه
العاجله لمتضررين تقدر عددهم بنحو 900 الف
وتناشد المانحين تقديم مساعدات باكثر من
70 مليون دولار
مع الاعلان عن انهيار 50 الف مسكن جراء
الزلزال جهود الانقاذ والاغاثه تتواصل في
المغرب والسلطات تعلن خطه فوريه لاواء
المتضررين واعاده اعمار المناطق المنكوبه
والتكفل بالفئات الاكثر تضررا
[موسيقى]
نبدا من تداعيات يا سيول في ليبيا حيث
يتكشف يوما بعد اخر حجم الفاجعه التي حلت
بشرق البلاد لا سيما مدينه درنه
[موسيقى]
اعلن الهلال الاحمر الليبي ان عدد
المفقودين جراء السيول والفيضانات في
مدينه درنه يتجاوز 10,000 شخص وفق معطيات
اوليه حتى الان واسفرت السيول والفيضانات
عن اختفاء احياء وانهيار جسور ودمار واسع
في شبكه الطرق لمدينه درنه وجوارها فيما
تكثف فرق الانغاز المحليه والاجنبيه
جهودها للبحث عن ناجين وانتشال ودفن الجثث
المتناثره في المدينه ويحذر المسؤولون
المحليون في المدينه من احتمال تفشي
الامراض والاوبئه بسبب انتشار الجفف
احمد خليفه احمد ضعنا اذا انكساره في سوره
اخر ما توفر لديك من معلومات ومعطيات عن
جهود الانقاذ التكفل بالمنكوبين وغيرها من
المعطيات في هذه الساعات احمد
بالنسبه لاخر جهود الانقاذ عبد القادر
اعلنت مصلحه الطرق والجسور الليبيه اليوم
انها رصدت انجرافات من ست مداخل رئيسيه من
الطريق الرئيسي الواقع غرب مدينه البيضاء
وقالت انها ستتعاقد مع شركات لفتح المداخل
في اسرع وقت وازاله الركام ومعالجه
الانجرافات ايضا الهيئه العامه للبحث
والتعرف على المفقودين في المنطقه الشرقيه
وفي سياق عملها في مدينه درنه اعلنت انها
باشرت في انتشال الجثث في مدينتي درنه
وسوسه واخذ عينات من الحمض النووي من
الجثث مجهوله الهويه ودعت من فقدوا احبتهم
افرادا من عائلاتهم واسرهم في هذه السيول
اذا تقديم بلاغات لدى الهيئه
لمطابقه الحمض النووي الذي يؤخذ من الجثث
في مدينه درنه وسوسه مع الحمض النووي الذي
يؤخذ من افراد هذه العائلات ايضا مركز
الطب والطوارئ اعلن في وقت سابق اليوم انه
نجح في انقاذ عائله
وشخصين كانوا محاصرين في منازلهم بعد مرور
خمسه ايام على الفيضانات في درنه ايضا في
وقت سابق اعلن رئيس الحكومه عبد الحميد
دبيبه ان فرق الانقاذ والاغاثه في دارنا
تمكنت من انقاذ ما يزيد عن 300 مفقود
بينهم ثلاثه عشر طفلا على الاقل ايضا وفي
سياق المساعدات الانسانيه القادمه
من كافه المدن الليبيه عبد القادر اشاد
بهذه الظاهره اشاد بها المبعوث الاممي الى
ليبيا عبد الله اباتيلي الذي اعلن قائلا
ان الشعب الليبي يضرب اعظم الامثله في
الوحده والتعاطف والصمود في مواجهه ما
وصفها هذه الماساه المدمره ايضا عبد الله
بتيري قال ارى امامي اليوم ليبيا واحده
موحده لشرق لغرب لا جنوب وطالب ايضا عبد
الله بتيلي السلطات والمؤسسات الليبيه على
مواصله وتنسيق جهود الاستجابه لهذه
الكارثه هذه ابرز التطورات في الساعه
الاخيره اما باشارتك للمساعدات احمد
الاوضاع المعيشيه
اسال عنه عن هذه المساعدات
هل تصل الى هذه المناطق المنكوبه خاصه في
درنه مع ازمه الجسور وازمه الطرقات هل تصل
بالنسبه للجسور والطرقات اليوم اذنت مصلحه
الجسور والطرق انها باشرت في رصد
الانجرافات وايضا رصد الطرق المدمره وانها
ستقوم بايجاد حلول بديله على سبيل المثال
كان هناك ايجاد حل بديل
لاحدى الطرق تحديدا الواقعه جنوب غرب
مدينه درنه هناك طرق جرفتها السيول
والفيضانات مصلحه الجسور اليوم اوجدت
طريقا او ما وصفتها بتحويل مؤقته في احدى
الطرق جنوب غرب درنه وبالتالي هذه قد تسهل
عمليه دخول المساعدات وفرق الانقاذ وفرق
المتطوعين الى مدينه درنه وبالفعل توفرت
لدينا معلومات ان هناك مساعدات دخلت
بالفعل الى مدينه درنه وبشر في توزيعها
على المحتاجين اليها من الاهالي المتضررين
من هذه السيول والفيضانات لكن الماساه
الانسانيه او الاوضاع المعيشيه كبيره
مترديه ومتراجعه بشكل كبير جدا في مدينه
درنه عبد القادر باعتبار ان السيول
والفيضانات ضربت خطوط الكهرباء وخطوط
المياه وخطوط حتى مياه الصرف الصحي ما ادى
الى
ما يمكن ان نصفه بالاختلاط بين المياه
الصالحه للشرب ومياه الصرف الصحي الان
تاكف الفرق الفنيه التابعه
للهيئه العامه للمياه والصرف الصحي على
سبيل المثال على اصلاح هذه الخطوط اليوم
اعلنت انها تواجه بعض الصعوبات وتواجه بعض
التحديات بسبب تهالك البنيه التحتيه وبسبب
فداحه الاضرار الناتجه عن السيول
والفيضانات لكن قالت انها هذه التحديات
لكنها تعمل جاهده على التغلب عليها ايضا
حتى امدادات الكهرباء شركه الكهرباء تمكنت
من اعاده الكهرباء الى درنا بشكل تدريجي
لم تعد الكهرباء كما كانت في وقت سابق
ايضا حتى الاتصالات لم تعد كما كانت في
وقت سابق لكنها بدل الانقطاع الكامل بدات
تعود بشكل تدريجي في هذا السياق ايضا
يواصل الاهالي البحث عن الجثث المزيد من
الجثث تحت ركامها المباني والجثث المضموره
تحت ركام المباني وتحت الطمي وفي برك
المياه التي تكونت
جراء هذه السيول والفيضانات ايضا هناك فرق
دوليه وفرق محليه تواصل البحث عن الجثث
التي جرفتها مياه السيول والقت بها في
البحر هناك مجهودات مماثله تبذل في هذا
الصدد ايضا الفرق الدوليه والاقليميه التي
وصلت الى مدينه درنه تواصل عملها بشكل
دؤوب اليوم على سبيل المثال عندما اعلن عن
العثور على ناجين ثمه من قال او من تحدث
ان العثور عليهم كان بعد تدخل
اقليميه استعملت تقنيه معينه في العثور
على هؤلاء الناجين احمد خليفه من طرابلس
شكرا جزيلا لك
بسم الله
اعتقد الحكومه بدلت
جهود كبيره كان ربما اولها وتخصيص مبالغ
ان شاء الله تعالى تكون
كافيه
لتعامل مع هذه الازمه الغير مسبوقه في في
تاريخ الشعب الليبي
جهود الاغاثه حقيقه يعني
تضافرت الوزارات كلها ممثله في وزاره
المواصلات
فتحت كثير من الطرق
المسدوده
بسبب الانهيارات التي صاحبت هذا
الفيضانات ايضا
تم يعني
برمجه كثير من الرحلات حقيقه يعني الجويه
الى مطار الابرق هذا من اقرب المطارات الى
الى قدرنا
الجبل الاخضر
وللحمد الاغاثه تسير على قدم وساق
برعايه
اللجنه
الازمه المشكله من الحكومه
ونسال الله يعني في الايام القادمه
ان يعني
نصل الى الى درجه جيده من ما اهم ما
يواجهكم من صعوبات سيدي ابراهيم
ما اهم يواجهكم من صعوبات سيدي الكريم
سالتك عن
الصعوباتنا من الصعوبات حقيقه
ربما الصعوبات تتمثل بالدرجه الاولى هو
الخوف من من حدوث
التلوث البيئي الذي ممكن يصاحب مثل هذه
الكوارث واخص بالدرجه الاولى والتلوث مياه
الشرب لان مصادر التلوث تحقيقا كبيره
وربما يعني نحتاج
لقمه الحذر وقمه
يعني
المسؤوليه في تعامل مع مصادر التلوث من
المتمثله حقيقه في جثه ربما التي الان
غامرتها السيول واصبحت مدفونه في الطين
وبصيره او باخرى وكذلك الحيوانات النافقه
واذا في اي مواد كيماويه موجوده بجرفها
السيل بالاضافه الى اختلاط ربما مياه صرف
صحي في في اغلب الاحوال وحيث ان الكثير من
الابار قد غمرت من قبل السيول حقيقه
لا نضمن
تلوث هذه الاعبار ويجب حقيقه على الجميع
على عدم استعمال وشدد عليها بصوره كبيره
جدا يجب الابتعاد عن استخدام اي مياه
موجوده داخل مدينه درنه بالخصوص وايضا
باقي المدن التي تعرضت
لبعض الانهيارات
فعليه يعني يجب اخذ الحيطه في في التعامل
لان نقل الامراض عن طريق الماء هذا امر
سريع جدا وحقيقه هذا ما يقلقنا ويخفنا في
هذه الصعوبات سيد ابراهيم هل الامكانيات
الداخليه كافيه ام تحتاجون لمساعدات من
الخارج في بعض التخصصات
في الحقيقه نحتاج الى اقولها لك
كثير من الدول التي ربما تفوقنا تقدما هذا
تحتاج الى مساعدات تاتيها من الغير يعني
بالامس القريب كان هناك زلزال في المغرب
وكان هناك زلزال في في في تركيا وراينا ان
تركيا على يعني
تقدمها وقوتها الاقتصاديه ولكن كان لابد
من وجود فرق حقيقه من الخارج تعين فهذا
ليس لا يعيبنا على الاطلاق نحن نقدم
معاونات للشعوب في حاله وجود كوارث
ويتوقع ايضا في حاله كانت عندنا ان
نحتاج الى مثل هذه المساعدات فهذا امر
طبيعي وعرف دوله تعرفت عليه الشعوب
الخارجيه سواء كانت دول او منظمات ماذا
طلبتم بالتحديد
والله هو ربما يعني بالدرجه الاولى يعني
الفرق
التعرف على
الضحايا
والانتشال يعني هذه ربما هذه اكثر صعوبه
لان لم نتعامل
ككلبين حقيقه
على الاقل في الذاكره الجمعيه للشعب
الليبي بلال لم نعرف مثل هذه الكارثه هذه
غير مسبوقه وبالتالي يصعب علينا ان
نتعامل يعني معها بمفردنا وعليه ربما يعني
برنامج التعرف على الضحايا وانتشالهم هذا
نحتاج فيه حقيقه الى معاونه الدول التي
ربما مرت بمثل هذه الكوارث في السابق
فهذا ربما كان البرنامج الاغلب سيدي
ابراهيم حتى مندوبه الامم المتحده سيدي
عبد الله بتيلي اشاد بهذا التكاتف بين
الليبيين هذا يدفعنا للسؤال عن هذه
المساعدات كيف يتم تنظيمها من اجل ايصالها
الى المناطق المتضرره
في الحقيقه اذا تكلمت عن المساعدات فيما
يخص اليغاتها من الماكل والمشرب
الليبيين اليوم ضربوا مثال حقيقه في
التعاضد والتالف يعني لدرجه السيد عبد
الله نفسه قال بالحرف يعني قال اليوم رايت
شعب واحد الشعب الليبي الى هناك شرق ولا
غرب ولا جنوب انا ايضا يعني اثمن على هذه
المقوله لانه
الناس خرجت حقيقه من كل حدب وصوب متجهه
الى درنه فرادى وجماعات يعني
كلها تتجه لتقديم المساعده ويد العون
فالمواد الاغاثيه متاكد ان الامور طيبه
وتسير بشيء حسن فقط انا دائما اؤكد على
واشدد على ان يتم توفير المياه بال هذه
التي زي ما ذكرت انا اخشى ما اخشاهوال قال
الامراض من الانسان يستخدم المياه
الموجوده حاليا في المناطق المنكوبه ولكن
اجمالا انا متاكد ان الليبيين يعني
استطاعوا انهم يثبتوا في الموعد
وباذن الله تعالى سنتجاوز هذه المرحله عن
قريب يعني طيب ابري على ما قلته قبل قليل
فيما يتعلق بتصريحات السيد عبد الله
باتيلي وهذه الصور صور التكاتف بين
الليبيين دليل على وحده الشعب الليبي انتم
كاسياسيين هل تنسقون ايضا فيما يتعلق
بكيفيه هل هناك قنوات تواصل بينكم وبين
بقيه الاطراف من اجل ايصال هذه المساعدات
وتجاوز هذه المحنه ومشاكل هذا التواصل
والله
ساقول لك يعني نعم هناك تواصل مع جميع
الاطراف انا حقيقه يعني
ليس سرا اني
ننسق مع ربما وزاره البيئه في الطرف الاخر
هذا يجب ان نتجاوز حاليا هذه المرحله
نظريه الشرق والغرب كل من الان امام كارثه
يجب ان نتكاتف ونتعاضد
ولله الحمد يعني لا يوجد حاليا انا لا احس
باي باي خلاف يعني نظريه الشرق الغربله
الان هي ورائي ليست امامي على الطاوله على
الطاقه
فالحمد لله يعني هناك تنسيق يناسبك حتى
بعض القنوات الفضائيه اللي محسوبه هنا
وهناك كلها موجوده الان في طرابلس وتستطيع
ان تبث من داخل طرابلس هذا شيء جيد جدا
وفي اتجاه الصحيح
شكرا لك سيد ابراهيم العربي منير وزير
البيئه في حكومه الوحده الوطنيه الليبيه
شكرا لك
معنا الان من درنا يوسف بشكورت وهو فني
البحث والانقاذ في فريق الانقاذ التابع
لهيئه الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه افاد سيد
يوسف كيف تصف لنا عملكم ماذا فعلتم في
ساعات الماضيه نوع الصعوبات
السلام
اولا
عندما جئنا هنا الى البرنامج مدينه برنه
كان الامور ليست جيده
سيء سيء جدا سيئه جدا لكن
بحثنا
بدانا الاعمال حالا وبعد ذلك
اولا
جئنا هنا بثلاثه طيران
180 اشخاص الذي بحث الانقاذ
بالسيارتين خمسه بوت وعندنا بدانا
موظف البحث والانقاذ حالا بعد ذلك
اسسنا هنا بعض الحميات التي المشفى
السكون الذي للناس
لاشخاصنا والان نحن هنا نحتاج الى بعض
الجرافات وال فقط كل شيء تمام باذن الله
طيب ماذا عن اهم الصعوبات التي تواجهكم
سيدي يوسف
المدينه في بدايه كان سيئه لكن
فرغوا الاجنبيون
تركي بعد
مدن مدن الفاره يوجد هنا كلب مثل تونس مثل
الجاريه مثل الجزائر مثل اسبانيا وفي هذه
الفارق نحن نعمل مع بعضنا باذن الله
سيكون كل شيء افضل
هل عدد الفرق الموجود حاليا كافي
الان نعم كافي لكن يوجد عندنا زياده اشخاص
سياتي هنا في يوم السبت ثلاثه السفن
ومساعده الناس ان شاء الله طيب كيف وجدتم
اوضاع الناس من حيث توفر الغذاء والماء
الصالح للشرب سيد يوسف
والماء
مشكله قليلا ناخذ الماء من
مع الشحنه لكن سيكون افضل ان شاء الله
طيب ماذا عن الجثث
والامل في وجود احياء
[موسيقى]
يوجد هناك احياء واحد اليوم لكن
يعني باذن الله نريد ان ننقذ اكثر في رقم
لكن الان نستطيع ان نجد واحد فقط
طيب ماذا عن التعامل مع الجثث
يوجد عندنا كافيه ونحن
جئنا لنا جئنا بعد الحميات التي مثل هذا
لسكون الناس
وداخله يوجد ايضا طاقه بالطعام والتنظيف
شكرا لك معنا من كنت معنا من درنا يوسف
باشكورت وانت فني البحث والانقاذ في فريق
الانقاذ التابع لهيئه الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه افاده
هذا وانا شدات الامم المتحده المانحين
تقديم اكثر من 71 مليون دولار خلال الاشهر
الثلاثه المقبله لتلبيه احتياجات نحو 200
وخمسين الف شخص تضرر من السيول في ليبيا
واعربت المنظمه عن قلقها من الارتفاع
المحتمل في اعداد الوفيات والمصابين اذا
لم يتم ارسال مساعدات على الفور واضافت
الامم المتحده ان تحليلا بالاقمار
الصناعيه اظهر ان 2200 مبنى تضررت بسبب
السيول وتستهدف المناشده نحو ربع
المتضررين بشكل مباشر فقط البالغ عددهم
884 الف شخص
فقد اعلن وكيل الامين العام للامم المتحده
للشؤون الانسانيه مارتن جريفيث تخصيص 10
ملايين دولار من صندوق الطوارئ لدعم
عمليات الاغاثه في ليبيا وقال ان حجم
كارثه الفيضانات في ليبيا صادم ومفجع وان
احياء باكملها مسحت من الخريطه
معنى من مقر الامم المتحده في نيويورك
فرحان حق نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده سيد فرحان كيف او ما خطه
الامم المتحده في التعامل مع هذه الكارثه
الامم المتحده بانها مفجعه
نعم قمنا باعداد مقرا في بنغازي يتم
ادارته من قبل
المنسق الانساني للسيد جونيان وهو المكان
الذي سنبدا فيه باطلاق عملياتنا منه فيما
يتعلق بجهود الاغاثه للشعب الليبي كما
ذكرت
كان هنالك مناشده انسانيه هي مناشده اوليه
ل71 مليون دولار وهذه تتعامل مع احتياجات
حوالين 250 الف شخص في ليبيا لكن اعتقده
ان العدد سيتزايد حتى قد ربما يصل الى 800
الف شخص بحاجه الى المساعدات بطريقه
وباخرى بالتالي سيكون هنالك تحديث لهذه
الارقام كان هنالك مبلغ اولي تم اطلاق
مناشده اليه كان هنالك
اموال من المناشده وحوالي كانت هذه
الاموال قد وصلت الى عشر ملايين دولار من
اجل ايصالها الى ليبيا وتوجيهها في جهود
الاغاثه بالتالي نحن نحاول ان نكون في
المقدمه ونسرع من عمليات الاغاثه ونحن
نامله الان هو ان الشعب
الليبي الذي انا بشكل كبير في السابق
سيتحدون مع بعضهم
البعضمنون ان المساعدات تصلوا الى الجميع
وان معاناه التي قد شهدتها عوائل كثيره قد
يتم الاجابه عنها برد موحد وطني ودولي
ماذا عن الامور الملحه السيد فرحان مثلا
ممثله متحدثه باسم المكتبه الاقليمي
للاغاثه على مستوى المتحده تحذر بان الوضع
الاغاثي في ليبيا خاصه في المناطق
المتضرره متدهور جدا وخطير
نعم هو خطر للغايه بالتالي نحن سنحاول ان
نوصل الغذاء باسرع وقت ممكن برنامج غذاء
العالمي وهو الجزء المتعلق بالغذاء في
الامم المتحده يتحدث عن ادخال المزيد من
الغذاء وكما قلت بدانا
بتحريك الاموال من اجل الايصال للمساعدات
بالتالي نحن سنحاول ايصال الغذاء والماء
والماء والادويه والاحتياجات
الاخرى الضروريه
الى منطقه درنه والمناطق المحيطه بها
باسرع وقت ممكن في ظل الانقسام السياسي
الحاصل في ليبيا مع من تنسقون سيد فرحان
جهودنا مع كل الاطراف على الارض اذا ما
كان استطاعتي الى هذا الامر احد الامر
الذي كان
مهما انه في ضم هذه الماساه فان الشعب
الليبي اتحد سويه ما استطعنا رؤيته فان
الانقسامات التي كانت موجوده في المجتمع
الليبي لم تكن ظاهره فيما يتعلق بالتعامل
مع الجهود المنسقه من اجل ايجاء ايصال
المساعدات لمن يحتاجها ونحن نامل ان يستمر
هذا الامر
وجهتم دعوات لجمع التبرعات لجمع المال كيف
تقيمون مدى الاستجابه حتى الان
نقوم بارسال هذه المناشدات المناشده كانت
اليوم ل 71 مليون دولار يوم الخميس بعد
التقييم الاولي للوضع ولوضع الكارثي هناك
بالتالي سنحن نبدا بضمان ان هذه ان الدول
الدول تقوم بارفاء بتعهداتها من الواضح
اننا سمعنا تعبيرات عن الدعم نريد هذا
الامر يتحول الى خطوات ملموسه وايضا
تبرعات ملموسه للشعب الليبي هل سيقتصر دور
الامم المتحده فقط على جمع المال ام لكم
ايضا ادوار اخرى هناك حاجه في ليبيا الى
ارسال فرق متخصصه في بعض المسائل تتلائم
مع هذه الكارثه
[موسيقى]
لقد قمنا بارسال فرق في ليبيا الى ليبيا
خلال اليومين الماضيه كما ذكرت فان المنسق
الانسان يناق جورج كونيون قد هو وصل الى
المركز مركز الاغاثه في بنغازي التابع لنا
الذي سنستخدمه
كمقر لتنسيق المساعد المساعدات الانسانيه
وايضا نقوم بارسال اشخاص الى هناك جزء من
ردنا استجابتنا عفوا الاضافيه شكرا لك من
مقر الامم المتحده في نيويورك فرحان حق
نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم
المتحده
بعد فاجعه الاعصار كارثه انسانيه ثانيه
تتربص بدرنه بلغه الارقام توصف الامم
المتحده حول الكارثه المحدثه بمناطق شمال
شرق ليبيا التي اجتاحها الاعصار تشمل
المناطق الاكثر تضررا درنا والبيضاء وسوسه
والمرج وشحات وتاكنس وبرسس وتوكرا
والابيار نحو
884 الف شخص يعيشون في هذه المناطق هم
بحاجه الان لمساعده عاجله 250 الفا من
هؤلاء يصنفون على انهم الفئه الاكثر
الحاحا تطلق الامم المتحده استغاثه عاجله
لتوفير 71 مليون و400 الف دولار لتوفير
اغاثات مستعجله لهؤلاء الوضع اكثر قتامه
في درنا تقدر السلطات هناك حصيله الضحايا
بما بين
180 الف قتيل اما عدد النازحين فتجاوز
ثلاثين الف شخص من اصل 200 الف هم سكان
المدينه وفي البيضاء توفق منظمه الهجره
الدوليه نزوح ثلاثه الاف شخص وفي بنغازي
اضطرت اكثر من 400 اسره لترك منازلها الى
مناطق اخرى يغادر الاعصار مدن الشرق
الليبي بلا اي بنيه تحتيه يقول الصليب
الاحمر ان ما لا يقل عن 140 منشاه تعليميه
تضررت كليا او جزئيا في المناطق التي
اجتاحها الاعصار اما القطاع الصحي فيشهد
انهيارًا تاما مع خروج نحو 128 منشاه صحيه
من الخدمه وفقا لصور الاقمار الصناعيه فان
اكثر من 2200 مبنى تهدمت ولم تعد صالحه
للعيش فيها
علمنا بنغازي هشام ابو شكيوات وزير طيران
البدني في الحكومه المكلفه من البرلمان
وعضو لجنه الطوارئ الوزير هشام ماذا عن
جهود ايصال المساعدات لهذه المناطق
المنكوبه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على اشرف الانبياء والمرسلين لا تزال فرق
الانقاذ والبحث وفي مسانده الجيش الليبي
على مستوى الافراد واليوسفين
تتسابق مع عقارب الساعه في محاوله للوصول
الى لاجئين وقد تمكنت فرق الانقاذ هذا
اليوم من انقاذ حوالي 15 شخص
تم انقاذهم وتم تسليمهم للمراكز الطبيه
داخل مدينه درنه هذه الاحصائيه احصائيه
مبدئيه قد تكون هناك بعد قد يكون هناك بعض
اللاجئين في بعض المناطق المجاوره لمدينه
درنه ولكن لم يتم تسجيلهم بطريقه
سليمه او عن طريق معلومات عن هؤلاء
الناجين كيف نجوا اين كانوا
طبعا هؤلاء الذين كانوا تحت اكوام
المباني التي انهارت عليهم وتم الوصول
اليهم بفضل
الخبرات الدوليه والمحليه التي وصلت الى
مدينه درنه وساعدت الحقيقه دور كبير في
الوصول
في اي منطقه تحديدا
في 15 الذي تم
انقاذهم اليوم هم من مدينه دارنا بالتحديد
طيب ماذا عن جهود الاغاثه والوصول الى هذه
الاماكن
في الحقيقه يعني هناك جسر زوجي
[موسيقى]
مطار مينا ومطار مبرق
جسر جوي محليا ودوليا اتت مساعدات من كل
حد وصوب من العاصمه طرابلس من الاخوه في
الغرب من الدول الشقيقه الحقيقه مساعدات
باحجام كبيره
وحتى على مستوى الافراد هناك حبه كبيره من
كل الشعب الليبي في الغرب في مدن الجبل
امازيغ
لمساعده اخوانهم في مدينه درنه ومعاق التي
حولها لدرجه اصبحت حتى هذه المساعدات
عندما تصل اصبحت مربكه كيفيه التعامل معها
وكيفيه تصنيفها وكيفيه توزيعها كميه
المساعدات اللي وصلت يعني الحمد لله كبيره
جدا
ويستلمها الجيش ويتعامل معها في توزيعها
وتوصيلها الاماكن المنكوبه او التي في
الاماكن التي لا تستطيع ان تصل اليها
بسيارات العاديه هل تلصقون السيد الوزير
مع هذه الجه الخارجيه لتحديد ما هي
احتياجاتكم
طبعا هناك
تنسيق
يومي معهم والكل يسال ما هي الاحتياجات
التي تحتاجها ونعطي فيهم في معلومات وبعض
الاحتياجات التي التي نفتقدها هنا ولكن
نستطيع القول للاحتياجات تم توفيرها حقيقه
بفضل يعني المساعدات البوليه من السواعد
الصعيد الدولي سواء على الدول الاشقاء
كذلك حتى على مستوى الافراد الليبيين ولكن
احد اعتقد احنا في مرحله حساسه وفي مرحله
التسابق مع الزمن وهو محاوله الوصول الى
لاجئين وهذا لن
يتاتى الا يتواجد الفرق التي لها خبره في
عمليه الانتشار والبحث عن المفقودين
الحقيقه وصول الفرق هذه عمله صار كبير في
عمليه الوصول
للناجين
ما زالت الى فرق متخصصه في عمليه البحث عن
ناجين
بالضبط سيدي فاضل هو منحتاجه فرق متخصصه
باجهزه متخصصه باكرمكم الله كلاب متخصصه
تستطيع التعرف عن وجود اماكن وجود
المفقودين او وجود الضحايا هذه سعاده
كثيرا في تقليص الوقت والذهاب مباشره الى
مكان وجود العالقه او مكان وجود الضحيه
لذلك الامم المتحده السيد الوزير هشام
تحذر من ازمه غذاء خاصه في درنه
يرتقي لمستوى الازمه على مستوى الغذاء كما
اسلفت
حاد في الغذاء
لا لا
اعتقد هذا دقيق الاغذيه الى حد ما موجوده
ولكن هناك اعتقد بان نحتاج الى اداره ازمه
توزيع هذا الغذاء الحقيقه يعني كميه
الاغذيه والمواطن الطبيه والاغطيه التي
وصلت مني المنطقه الغربيه ومن حتى ليس
مؤسسه الدوله حتى على مستوى افراد وامه
مناطق كبير جدا يعني لم ينقطع الجسر
الجوي ولم تنقطع هل تستطيعون ايصالها الى
كل مناطق المنكوبه الى كل المحتاجين
نعم نعم القوات الجيش تستلم في هذه
المساعدات وتعمل على توصيل عن الاماكن
المنكوبه لذلك يعني اعتقد الاولويه تكون
كما اسلفت لي ارسال
فرق التفتيش والمحيط
شكرا لك من بنغازي هشام وزير الطيران
المدني في الحكومه المكلفه من البرلمان
وعضو لجنه الطوارئ شكرا جزيلا لك
في مقابله مع الجزيره قادر المتحدث باسم
جهاز الاسعاف والطوارئ الليبي اسامه علي
انها فرق البحث والانقاذ وصلت الى الجانب
الشرقي من مدينه درنه
جيد ما يتطور في عمليات البحث والانقاذ
يعني توسع الرقعه والدخول الى الجانب
الشرقي من المدينه الدخول الى الجانب
الشرقي من المدينه كان متعثر في الفتره
الماضيه الان وبعد صيانه الطريق الشرقي
الذي يدخل للمدينه بشكل مباشر
لفرق الطوارئ الان دخلت موديله البارحه
تحديدا من المدينه قامت بانتشال عدد من
الجثث من داخل الجانب الشرقي مع العلم من
الجانب الشرقي ليس متضرر كما هو متضرر
الجانب الغربي وايضا كان فيه انتشال من
ميناء درنه اضافه ان هناك الفرق الدوليه
التي تعمل في اماكن اخرى ومتفرقه هي رقعه
البحث الان اتسعت حتى وصلت الى ما يقارب
العشره كيلو متر مربع
مع مروج الايام تتواصل عمليات الانقاذ
والبحث عن الجثث في مدينه درنه والوادي
الكبير مع صعوبه بالغه في الوصول الى
الجانب الشرقي من المدينه بعد تهدم الجسور
لكن تتكشف مع الوقت ايضا تفاصيل ازمه
الوصول الى هؤلاء مع تغيير كبير طرا على
جغرافيا المدينه
بعض الجثث لا احد عندها ربما لم يبقى احد
من عائلاتهم ليتعرف عليهم هذه هي الايام
التاليه للكارثه في ليبيا يتواصل البحث عن
المفقودين احياء او جثثا وهؤلاء بالالاف
الوصول اليهم محفوف بازمه حقيقيه تتكشف
صورها كل ساعه فدرنا اصبحت مدينتين كانت
تتربع على ضفتي الوادي يربطهما خمسه جسور
انهارت بالكامل مع انهيار هذه الجسور قطعت
اوصال المدينه اصبح الوصول الى الجزء
الشرقي صعبا للغايه وفق رئيس لجنه الطوارئ
في حكومه الوحده فان العمل جاري الان على
مسارات بديله وفتح ممرات امنه امام فرق
البحث والانقاذ الطريق الوحيد الان هو
الظهر الحمر وفيه تتكدس سيارات المتطوعين
والناس في المدينه وخارجها الذين يريدون
المساعده طريق واحد فقط يوصل كل الى دارنا
بعد ايام من البحث المتواصل يبدو الامر
اسهل نسبيا في المدن الاخرى مثل سوسه
والبيضاء هناك تم انجاز مسارات بديله بشكل
اسرع ووصلت الفرق الى المناطق المتضرره من
ضمن المسارات المنشوده البحر قبل ساعات
اعلن ان ميناء دارنا قادر على استقبال
السفن قد يساعد الامر في الوصول الى
المناطق الشرقيه من المدينه ازمه اخرى
تفرض نفسها الان وهي انهيار 80% من
العبارات والمجاري المائيه في درنه هذا
يعني ان مسطحات مائيه كبيره تتشكل في
المدينه دون التصريف لا احد يعلم ما الذي
ابتلعته هذه المسطحات المائيه في كل انحاء
المدينه المؤكد حتى الان ان المياه غمرت
اكثر من 900 الف متر مربع من درنه
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه الليبيه
عبد الحميد الدبيبه ان الوثائق كشفت وجود
اموال خصصت لصيانه السدود في درنه لكن هذه
الاموال لم تستخدم لغرضها واضافها في
اجتماع الحكومي ان وزاره التخطيط تقول ان
هذه العقود لم تستكمل
موضوع الشدود الموضوع
اللي مش واضح للعيال ولا يتفكر في حد
ولا يندر عليه حد وحتى العقود هذين في حد
يدوي عليها بلديه بتجوا عليهن
ولا
خصوصا الا بعد تصير الكوارث هذه كلها
وبيقولوا
وين السدود ومنو اللي مسؤول عليها
اختراق وما فيش
صدعوا هذاك كذا احنا توا من خلال الورق
وزاره التخطيط اكتشفت انه عندنا عقود
وعندنا صيانه ولم تستكمل
في اجتماع الحكومه ان جميع المسؤولين ومن
ضمنهم رئيس الحكومه ووزاره المياه يتحملون
مسؤوليه اداره السدود وصيانتها
بشكل او باخر ان يعتقدنا تحمل المسؤولين
كلنا الليبينه
ولكن ان يعلي راسكم يتحمل هذه المسؤوليه
وانتم بعد كوزاره المياه تحملوا مسؤوليه
الموت الناس اللي مسؤوليتي دارت هذه
السدود
ادارتها والله والله صيانتها
وبدوره اكد رئيس المجلس الرئاسي محمد
المنفي ورئيس ديوان المحاسبه خالد بن شكشك
اكد ضروره تجهيز جميع الادله الداعمه
لتحقيقات النائب العام المتعلقه بانهيار
السدي مدينه درنه وتعطيل جهود الاغاثه
الدوليه للمنكوبين كما اكد المنيفي وشكشك
ضروره اتخاذ كل ما يلزم من اجراءات
استثنائيه لتذليل المشاكل والصعوبات من
اجل تخفيف المعاناه عن المواطنين
الى المغرب والمشهد في ختام اليوم مع
اقتراب الزلزال من اكمال يومه السادس فقد
نتمكنت فرق الانقاذ من اخراج امراه من تحت
الانقاض بعد مرور سته ايام على الزلزال
الذي ضرب وسط البلاد في غضور ذلك تستمر
عمليه فتح الطرق الجبليه المؤديه الى
القرى النائيه وسط مخاوف من انهيارات
صخريه جديده وكانت وزاره الداخليه قد
افادت بارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال الى
2946 والبوصابين الى خمسه الاف وسبعين
لو افاد الديوان الملكي المغربي انه تم
تفعيل المرحله الاولى من خطه طارئه لاواء
متضرري الزلزال وتشمل 50 الف مسكن من
انهارت كليا او جزئيا في الاقاليم الخمسه
المتضرره وفي اجتماع عمل حكومي اشرف عليه
العاهل المغربي تم اقرار خطه ايواء مؤقت
في هذه المناطق تاخذ بعين الاعتبار تحديات
كثيره بينها الامطار وتراجع درجات الحراره
كما تقرر صرف تقرر صرف مساعدات ماليه
مباشره لتسريع اعمال البناء او اعاده
تاهيل المساكن التي انهارت جزئيا وطالب
العاهل المغربي باستجابه سريعه وقويه
تحترم كرامه السكان
لتفاصيل اكثر نذهب الى عثمان اي فرح وجوله
رفقه مراسلنا على الارض من هناك عثمان
شكرا عبد القادر بالفعل للعاهل المغربي
الملك محمد السادس عقد اجتماع عمل وذلك
لتفعيل الاجراءات الخاصه
باعاده بناء المباني المتهزمه وايضا ايواء
المتضررين واتخذت عده قرارات من ضمنها
توفير ثلاثه ما يعادل ثلاثه الاف دولار
لكل اسره متضرره ايضا ما يعادل 8000 دولار
لكل بيت تم يعني دمر جراء زلزال جزئيا وما
يعادل 14,000 دولار ايضا للمباني التي او
المنازل التي تهدمت بشكل كامل وتم احصاء
نحو 50 الف منزل في خمسه تقاليم منها
شيشاوه وتارودانت والحوز الامن الحوز ينضم
الينا من قريه مولاي ابراهيم المختار
العلاوي وتنضم الينا ميساء الفطناسي من
تحناوت في اقليم الحوزه ايضا ميساء طبعا
المطلب الاول للمنكوبين الان يكاد يكون هو
الخيام هناك سحف الخيام ولكن يبدو انها
بدات يعني عدد لا باس به بالوصول تباعا
على الاقل في المنطقه التي انت موجوده
فيها
نعم عثمان هذا مطلب اساسي ان يجد
المتضررون من الزلزال ماوى ياويهم بعد ان
غادروا منازلهم لانها باتت غير قادره على
ان تضمهم تحت سقفها لان اسقفها ولان
جدرانها تضررت بشكل كبير بفعل الزلزال
الاخير اذا اثار الاثار الصعبه والقويه
لهذا الزلزال لا تقف فقط عند حدود القتلى
رحمهم الله او المصابين او المنازل التي
هدمت وتشققت وانما الوضع الذي يعيشه هؤلاء
في الصوره المظلمه التي تظهر خلفي داخل
الخيام التي بنوها واسسوها
بامكانياتهم الفرديه البسيطه وبالتالي فان
هذه الخيام بمقوماتها الحاليه غير قادره
على توفير الامان لهؤلاء الناس الذين
يبيتون ليلتهم هذه ولياليهم الماضيه وربما
لا يليهم القادم لا نعرف الى متى سيستمر
الامر تحت هذه الخيام البسيطه حتى انه لا
توجد اناره تكشف لهم ربما سلامه المكان
الذي يبيتون فيه ولكن عثمان الناس الذين
يطالبون بزياده الخيام لضمان اماكن تحويهم
اماكن يبيتون فيها لياليهم القادمه يبدو
ان مطالبهم تجد اذانا صاغيه اذ انه منذ
قليل وخلال الساعات الماضيه تابعنا ان
جهات الرسميه كانت قد اتت محمله
بهياكل لبيوت تركيب سيتم تركيزها هنا في
هذه في هذا المكان هذه البيوت ستكون يعني
بلا شك افضل من هذه الخيام بالنسبه لهؤلاء
لهذه العائلات التي تبيت لياليها هنا
باعتبار انها ستكون مجهزه
بالحد الادنى ربما من الو التي يحتاجها
الناس هنا لقضاء حوائجهم اليوميه هذا ربما
قد يفرح الناس هنا قليلا ولكن المزاج
العام هنا يظل مزاج محكوم بالخوف خصوصا
عثمان مع تتالي الهزات الارتداديه خلال
اليومين الماضيين وهذا ما يجعل الناس ربما
يعيشون ايامهم القادمه في مزيد من الخوف
ومزيد من الرفض للعوده الى منازلهم في
الوقت الحالي على الاقل مع تواصل هذه
التداعيات التي تجعلهم يخافون من مجرد
الاقتراب من منازلهم المتضرره بفعل
الزلزال الاخير
نعم ويتم الانتقال من مرحله معالجه الجرحى
وانتشار الجثث والاواء المؤقت الى المرحله
المقبله المتعلقه ببناء ما تهدم وعوده
الناس الى حياتهم الطبيعيه طبعا مع عوده
هذه الحياه الطبيعيه اصلا مع وقف الهزات
الارتداديه التي لم تقف بعد ان لم تكن
كبيره وان لم تكن اثارها ايضا كثيره
المختار ماذا عن قريه مولاي ابراهيم كيف
يعيش الناس ليلتهم هناك
نعم عثماني يعيشون في اجواء مغايره
للاجواء التي كانوا يعيشونها سابقا قبل
الزلزال ليس هو ما بعد الزلزال نحن الان
في خيمه عائله بن بركه بن بركه التي اقامت
هذه الخيمه لتعيش مجتمعه سيدي محمد سلام
الله عليكم على سلامتكم
واحد القوه سريعه
وجمعه
المهم
يلاه الناس يلاه
قوه ديك القهوه باش ضرب خطيره مرعبه
بالحيوط
في الرباط كيف تلقيت الخبر
عند تلقين الخبر هو احساسنا بالعجز
الارضيه
يعني كلنا كنقلبو على البؤره
في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بانه البؤره
كاينه في اقليم الحوز يعني
والاخوان ديالنا
بعض الله يبارك
الشبكه عاد الحمد لله بان اطمئنت على
العائله ديالي الاخوات الاخوان دياولي
بانه عندي عندي ثلاثه الاخوان ساكنين في
الدوار اخ ديالي سلك على على شويه يلاه
ولا تجرح ولا
هذا
عبد الرحمن الان كيف تعيشون يوميات
الزلزال
عندنا ولا عند وليداتنا كاينه
سلمان نفسيه باقي لازم باقي فيه ديك
الخلعه ديال الزلزال اكثريه بان بعد
الخسرات
اكثر منا سميتو عليه من
الاول كيف تصف القوه قوه الدمار الذي حقق
تسبب فيه الزلزال
الدرجات كتعرف بان سبعه
واللي باقي واقفين كاع مثلا باقي مشقوقين
عليها ما يقدر حتى واحد يدخل لهذاك المنزل
ديالو
فهمتي
بان واحد الرعب واحد الرعب خلاه فينا بان
ما عمرنا حنا
دار الزلزال ذاك النهار راه واحد الصوت
راه باقي
سيدي محمد المنطقه ديال الحوز تعرف في
العاده بالفيضانات
هذه الفتره جات زلزال شنو هو الفرق ما بين
الفيضان والزلزال كيجيب
واحد القوه
[موسيقى]
الوقت الاثار ديالو تبقى مستمره
الناس
نعم اذا تقريبا عثمان هذا جانب من الصوره
حيث تعيش الاسره المغربيه كانت تعيش في
منازلها اليوم في واقع جديد في الخيمه الى
اشعار اخر
الى اشعار اخر اذا شكرا لك المختار اللعب
لاوي من قريه مولاي ابراهيم في اقليم
الحوز واشكر كذلك في اقليم الحوز تحديدا
في تحناوت ميساء الفطناسي ونعود الان الى
عبد القادر
شكرا لك يا عثمان شبكه مراسلي الجزيره
نبقى دائما في هذا الشان هذه المره من
مراكش معنا من هناك الدكتوره انصاف ايه
صوابلي مسؤوله مركز طبي خاص الدكتوره
انصاف مرت سته ايام بعد الزلزال كيف
تقيمنا الوضع عندكم على المستوى الصحي
السلام عليكم وعليكم السلام
انا على متابعه بالنسبه للاوضاع حاليا
نقدروا نقولوا اننا قدرنا نسيطر على الوضع
من طرف الطبي الصحي ولا من الطرف المعنوي
حيث ان المساهمات والمساعدات الطبيه ولا
الماديه ما توقفوش منذ وقوع الكارثه الحمد
لله كيفما قدرنا اننا نتغلبو على وباء
كورونا الان تحت امتحان الزلزال ان شاء
الله غادي نتغطاوه
ما نوع الحالات التي ما زالت عندكم في
المستشفى
السيطره
بفضل قرار الملكي السامي وخدمه السلطات من
الامن والطاقم الانقاذ الحمد لله اغلب
الدواوير قدرنا حنا المغاربه بفضل
المساهمات والمساعدات الساكنه الان راها
في ظروف لا باس بها على الاقل هي تحت
الخيام والحمد لله الشعب المغربي والعربي
بصفه عامه
[موسيقى]
كيمتازوا بالتضامن مع بعضهم كبيره دكتوره
انصاف
[موسيقى]
زعما خطيره وما كاينش عدد ديال الجراحه
اللي زعما كثير
طيب ماذا عن التكفل بهؤلاء
مستشفياتهم مراكز الخاصه
طيب ماذا عن الاماكن النائيه والبعيده
والحالات فيها
الحمد لله
متضامنين مع بعضهم بفضل المساعدات
والمساهمات الساكنه الان راها كيف قلت لك
في ظروف لا باس بها قدرنا اننا نوفروليهم
الخيام
والاكل والمؤونه ديالهم وكل شيء عندهم
راهم بخير وعلى خير في انتظار انهم يبداوا
البناء ديالهم لان القرار الملكي اعطى
اننا انهم يبنيوا لهم
السكن ديالهم
شكرا لك من مراكش الدكتوره انصاف ايه
الصوابني مسؤوله مركز طبي خاص كنت معنا في
هذه المتابعه لاخر الاخبار والمستجدات
المتعلقه بالزلزال في المغرب بعدما طوى
يومه السادس
في اخبار اخرى قالت مصادر في ولايه شمال
كردفان هذه المره السودانيه للجزيره ان
قوات الدعم السريع انتشرت منذ امس
الاربعاء في مدينه ام روابه ثاني اكبر مدن
الولايه واشارت المصادر الى ان الجيش
السوداني كان قد سيطر على المدينه يوم
الثلاثاء الماضي ثم انسحب منها امس نحو
مدينه كوستي بولايه النيل الابيض من جهتها
قالت مصادر بالحكومه للجزيره ان قوات
الدعم السريع نهبت عشرات السيارات واحتجزت
بشكل غير قانوني اكثر من 30 شخصا في مدينه
ام روبا اطلقت سراح بعضهم لاحقا وفي
العاصمه الخرطوم افادت مصادر محليه
للجزيره بان الجيش السوداني قصف بالمدفعيه
مواقع للدعم السريع حول حيي جبرا وابو ادم
جنوبي المدينه
قال قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
دقلو في تسجيل صوتي منسوب له ان قوتي
الدعم السريع ستبدا مشاورات لتشكيل ما
سماه سلطه بدنيه في المناطق الخاضعه
لسيطارتها ردا على ما سماه بمحاوله قائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان ادعاء شرعيه
زائفه
واضاف واضاف قائد الدعم السريع ان قيام
البرهان بتشكيل حكومه مقرها يعني الاتجاه
نحو سيناريوهات حدثت في دول اخرى بوجود
طرفين يسيطران على مناطق مختلفه في بلد
واحد واكد حميدتي ان قوات الدعم السريع
بامكانها دخول مدينه بورسودان اذا ارادت
قالت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه في بيان انه
استمرارا لجهود المملكه وسلطنه عمان
للتوصل لوقف اطلاق نار دائم وشامل في
اليمن والتوصل لحل سياسي مستدام ومقبول من
كافه الاطراف فقد وجهت المملكه دعوه لوفد
من صنعاء لزياره السعوديه وذلك لاستكمال
اللقاءات والنقاشات بناء على المبادره
السعوديه المعلنه عام 2021 حسب بيان
للخارجيه السعوديه
مستمرون معكم في هذه التغطيه وفي عناوينها
عمليات البحث تتسع في درنه مع تمكن فرق
الانقاذ لاول مره من دخول الجزء الشرقي من
المدينه الامم المتحده تطلق نداء للاغاثه
العاجله لمتضررين تقدر عددهم بنحو 900 الف
وتناشد المانحين تقديم مساعدات باكثر من
70 مليون دولار
مع الاعلان عن انهيار 50 الف مسكن جراء
الزلزال جهود الانقاذ والاغاثه تتواصل في
المغرب والسلطات تعلن خطه فوريه لاواء
المتضررين واعاده اعمار المناطق المنكوبه
والتكفل بالفئات الاكثر تضررا
[موسيقى]
ان تداعيات يا سيول في ليبيا حيث يتكشف
يوما بعد اخر حجم الفاجعه التي حلت بشرق
البلاد لا سيما مدينه درنه
[موسيقى]
الاحمر الليبي ان عدد المفقودين جراء
السيول والفيضانات في مدينه درنا يتجاوز
10,000 شخص وفق معطيات اوليه واسفرت
الطيور والفيضانات عن اختفاء احياء
وانهيار جسور ودمار واسع في شبكه الطرق
لمدينه درنه وجوارها فيما تكشف او فما
تكثف فرق الانقاذ المحليه والاجنبيه
جهودها للبحث عن ناجين وانتشالي ودفن
الجثث المتناثره في المدينه ويحذر
المسؤولون المحليون في المدينه من احتمال
تفشي الامراض والاوبئه بسبب انتشار الجثث
مراسل الجزيره احمد خليفه اهلا بك احمد
نشاهد خلفك هذا الاجتماع لهؤلاء هل هو
مركز لجمع التبرعات وماذا عن اخر المعطيات
احمد
انا موجود في عزاء جماعي لضحايا السيول في
مدينه درنه عبد القادر هذا العزاء يقيمه
اهالي العاصمه طرابلس وتحديدا في منطقه
تاجوره الواقعه شرق العاصمه طرابلس لاهالي
ضحايا السيول في مدينه درنا يقام هذا
العزاء هنا في منطقه تاجوره ويقام ايضا
هناك عزاء اخر في وسط العاصمه طرابلس
تحديدا في منطقه زاويه الدهماني يتجه هذه
العاصمه طرابلس والمدن المجاوره الى هذين
العزائين لتقديم التعازي لاهالي درنا
المقيمين منهم والمهجرين في مدينه طرابلس
هناك اعداد كبيره من ضحايا السيول
والفيضانات في مدينه درنه لديهم اقارب هنا
في العاصمه طرابلس تحدثنا مع اقاربهم هناك
فقد اكثر من 30 وهناك من فقد اكثر من
اربعين وهناك من فقد اكثر من خمسه عشر
فردا من عائلته جراء هذه السيول
والفيضانات ففي هذين العزائين يلتقي اهالي
درنه مع معزيهم من مدينه طرابلس ومن المدن
والمناطق المجاوره
لتقديم العذاب
ايضا في في سياق الحديث عن ازمه
درنه عبد القادر تحاول الادارات الحكوميه
معالجه الازمه الانسانيه خاصه في مدينه
درنه اعلنت شركه الكهرباء على سبيل المثال
ان هناك فرق تابعه لها وصلت من المنطقه
الغربيه من ليبيا الى مدينه اجدابيه في
الشرق الليبي وتتجه الى مدن الجبل الاخضر
التي
جرفتها السيول
وهاجمتها السيول ومنها مدن المرج والبيضاء
ودرنا التي كانت السيول فيها اكثر وطءه من
غيرها شركه الكهرباء قالت ان المهندسين
والفنيين بالشركه يواصلون صيانه الاعطال
التي لحقت بخطوط الطاقه ومحطات الكهرباء
وصيانه الكوابل
ومنها على سبيل المثال خط توليد منطقه
الفتائح في ادرنه وهي خط ذات او ذو جهد 30
الف كيلو فولت اضافه الى صيانه الاعمده
الخشبيه التي
دمرتها السيول والفيضانات في درنا ايضا
وفي سياق تعليقه عبد القادر على المساعدات
الانسانيه التي اتجهت من كافه المدن
الليبيه الى مدينه درنه علق المبعوث
الامامي الى ليبيا عبد الله باتيلي على
هذه المساعده وعلى هذه القوافل
الاغاثيه التي تحمل مؤنا مختلفه وتحمي
الادويه وموادئ غاثيه مختلفه قال بتيني ان
الشعب الليبي يضرب اعظم الامثله في الوحده
الوطنيه والتعاطف في مواجهه ما وصفها هذه
الماساه المدمره وقال ايضا اباتيلي ارى
اليوم امامي الشعب الليبي
واحدا موحدا لا شرق ولا غرب ولا جنوب
وطالب عبد الله بتيري السلطات والمؤسسات
الليبيه على مواصله وتنسيق جهود الاستجابه
الى هذه الكارثه ايضا وفي سياق اخر وهو
سياق معالجه الاوضاع الانسانيه المتراجعه
في مدينه درنه عبد القادر اعلنت شركه
مصلحه اعلنت مصلحه الجسور والطرق عن رصدها
لعدد من الانجرافات في المداخل الغربيه
لمدينه درنه وقالت انها بصدد معالجه هذه
الانجرافات بالتعاقد مع شركات محليه
لمعالجه هذه الطرق في اسرع وقت ممكن مما
سيمهد الطريق امام القوافل قوافل المساعده
والدعم والاعانه والاغاثه الذاهبه الى
مدينه درنه والتي بالفعل هناك عدد منها
دخل الى مدينه
ايضا في سياق الجهود المبذوله داخل مدينه
درنه سواء من الفرق الفنيه الفرق المحليه
او الفرق الدوليه الباحثه عن الجثث
وانتشال الجثث اعلن اليوم عن
اعلن عن انتشار عدد من هذه الجثث وايضا في
المقابل اعلن عن انقاذ اسره وشخصين اخرين
من احدى المناطق التي حاصرتها السيول في
وقت سابق
احمد خليفه من طرابلس شكرا جزيلا لك
الامم المتحده المانحين تقديم اكثر من 71
مليون دولار خلال الاشهر الثلاثه المقبله
لتلبيه احتياجات نحو 250 الف شخص تضرروا
من السيول في ليبيا وعربت المنظمه عن
قلقها من الارتفاع المحتمل في اعداد
الوفيات والمصابين اذا لم يتم ارسال
مساعدات على الفور واضافت الامم المتحده
ان تحليلا بالاقمار الصناعيه اظهر ان 21
مبنى تضررت بسبب السيول وتستهدف المناشده
نحو ربع المتضررين بشكل مباشر فقط البالغ
عددهم
84 الف شخص
وقد اعلن وكيل الامين العام للامم المتحده
للشؤون الانسانيه مارتن جريفيث تخصيص 10
ملايين دولار من صندوق الطوارئ لدعم
عمليات الاغاثه في ليبيا وقال جريفث ان
حجم كارثه الفيضانات في ليبيا صادم ومفجع
وان احياء باكملها مسحت من الخريطه
بعد فاجعه الاعصار كارثه انسانيه ثانيه
تتربص بدرنه بلغه الارقام توصف الامم
المتحده حول الكارثه المحدثه بمناطق شمال
شرق ليبيا التي اجتاحها الاعصار تشمل
المناطق الاكثر تضررا والبيضاء وسوسا
والمرج وشحات وتاكنس وبيرسس وتوكرا
والابيار نحو
884 الف شخص يعيشون في هذه المناطق هم
بحاجه الان لمساعده عاجله 250 الفا من
هؤلاء يصنفون على انهم الفئه الاكثر
الحاحا تطلق الامم المتحده استغاثه عاجله
لتوفير 71 مليون و400 الف دولار لتوفير
اغاثات مستعجله لهؤلاء الوضع اكثر قتامه
في درنا تقدر السلطات هناك حصيله الضحايا
بما بين
180 الف اما عدد النازحين فتجاوز 30 الف
شخص من اصل 200 الف هم سكان المدينه وفي
البيضاء توثق منظمه الهجره الدوليه نزوح
ثلاثه الاف شخص وفي بنغازي اضطرت اكثر من
400 اسره لترك منازلها الى مناطق اخرى
يغادر الاعصار مدن الشرق الليبي بلا اي
بنيه تحتيه يقول الصليب الاحمر ان ما لا
يقل عن 140 منشاه تعليميه تضررت كليا او
جزئيا في المناطق التي اجتاحها الاعصار
اما القطاع الصحي فيشهد انهيارا تاما مع
خروج نحو 128 منشاه صحيه من الخدمه وفقا
لصور الاقمار الصناعيه فان اكثر من 2200
مبنى تهدمت ولم تعد صالحه للعيش فيها
عن تحركات ومتابعات الامم المتحده معنا من
مقر الامم المتحده في نيويورك مراسل
الجزيره مراد هاشم مراد
مرحبا عبد القادر بطبيعه الحال هذه
الارقام التي وردت في بيان النداء
الانساني الذي وجهته اليوم الامم المتحده
من اجل اغاثه منكوبي الفيضانات في ليبيا
مبنيه في الاساس على تقييم اول قامت به
الامم المتحده بالتعاون مع منظمات انسانيه
اخرى وكذلك السلطات الليبيه
وهناك فريق في الواقع الان في بنغازي فريق
اممي لاستكمال عمليات التقييم من اجل ايضا
تقييم اكثر دقه لهذه الاحتياجات بطبيعه
الحال ما قد يغير حجم الاحتياجات المطلوبه
وهذه الارقام كما هو متوقع التحركات هنا
الجديد فيها تلك التي قام بها مندوب ليبيا
تحديدا لقاءات مع رئيس الجمعيه العامه
ومكتب الامين العام وكذلك ممثلي المنظمات
والوكالات الامميه هنا من اجل الحشد الدعم
الدولي لدى السلطات الليبيه قلق لا سيما
فيما يتعلق بالتنسيق هناك تداعي دولي في
الواقع واستجابه سريعه من كثير من الدول
ولكن هناك حاجه للتنسيق بين هذه الجهود
وايضا لتلبيه الاولويات هناك حاجه تحديدا
الى على سبيل المثال كما اشار المندوب في
مؤتمر صحفي الى المعدات
لاستكمال عمليات الانقاذ بطبيعه الحال
هناك ايضا اشارات الى الحاجه على المد على
المدى البعيد الى
الاحتياجات اكبر من اجل اعاده الاعمار ماء
تضرر بطبيعه الحال هناك الاعلان عن عدم
مشاركه الرئيس مجلس
الرئاسه الاعلى في ليبيا وكذلك رئيس حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه بسبب الكارثه عدم
مشاركتهما في الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده اللافت ان المندوب الليبي حينما
سئل عن اثر الانقسام السياسي الليبي
على الاستجابه الانسانيه لهذه الكارثه هو
قال ان هناك حاله من الوحده اللافته
ابداها الشعب الليبي وتضامن كبير وان وانه
لا توجد على الاطلاق اي عوائق اداريه فيما
يتعلق بايصال المساعده وان اي مساعدات
متوفره يتم ايصالها سريعا الى المناطق
المتضرره وان هناك عوائق لوجستيه مثل
التضرر الطرق بطبيعه الحال
النداء الانساني الدولي الذي الذي اطلقته
الامم المتحده
سبق بالاعلان عن تخصيص مبلغ عشره مليون
عشره ملايين دولار من اجل القيام
بالعمليات اللغات الطارئه حتى الان الامم
المتحده عملياتها الانسانيه حتى هذه
اللحظه قاصره على القيام
بايصال المواد الطبيه
الايام مما كان متوفرا في مخازن وكالاتها
في ليبيا كما هو معروف هناك تواجد لهذه
الوكالات بحكم الوضع
الانساني الناجم عن الازمه السياسيه
والحرب في ليبيا كما هو معروف ولكن وكما
اشار السفير هذه الكميات ليست كافيه
بطبيعه الحال وان كانت الاستجابه الامميه
سريعه حجم الاحتياجات الكبير الاحتياجات
الانسانيه كانت تقدرها الامم المتحده قبل
كارثه الفيضان
ب 328 الف شخص يحتاجون الى مساعده الان هي
تقدر حجم الاحتياجات
يزيد عن
484 الف شخص يحتاجون في خمس مناطق خمس
محافظات في ليبيا وليس في درنا فقط
يحتاجون الى عمليات اغاثه جرى هذه الكارثه
عبد القادر ورد هاشم من مقر الامم المتحده
في نيويورك شكرا جزيلا لك
في مقابله مع الجزيره قادر المتحدث باسم
جهاز الاسعاف والطوارئ الليبي اسامه علي
ان فرق البحث والانقاذ وصلت الى الجانب
الشرقي من مدينه درنه
جيد ما يتطور في عمليات البحث والانقاذ
يعني توسع الرقعه والدخول الى الجانب
الشرقي من المدينه الدخول الى الجانب
الشرقي من المدينه كان متعثر في الفتره
الماضيه الان وبعد صيانه الطريق الشرقي
الذي يدخل للمدينه بشكل مباشر
لفرق الطوارئ الان دخلت منذ ليله البارحه
تحديدا من المدينه قامت بانتشال عدد من
الجثث من داخل الجانب الشرقي مع العلم من
الجانب الشرقي ليس متضرر كما هو متضرر
للجانب الغربي وايضا كان فيه انتشال من
ميناء درنه اضافه ان هناك الفرق الدوليه
التي تعمل في اماكن اخرى ومتفرقه هي رقعه
البحث الان اتسعت حتى وصلت الى ما يقارب
العشره كيلو متر مربع
معنا منا طرابلس منصور الحصادي عضو المجلس
الاعلى للدوله عن مدينه درنه سيد منصور
بابدا معك ببعض حتى الان ما يقدم من
الارقام بعض الوكاله تتكلم على ان عدد
الضحايا قد تجاوز الان العدد 11 وحوالي
300 ضحيه حتى الان
تحيه طيبه لك وللساده المشاهدين
والمستمعين طبعا ما زالت الكارثه مستمره
في مناطق الشرق الليبي وعلى راسها مدينه
درع الان وصلتني معلومه ان من مدينه درنه
ان عدد الشهداء الاحصار بلغ 6000
والمفقودين قرابه تسعه الاف مواطن من في
مدينه درنه طبعا سيدي الكريم انا اكرر من
خلال قناه الجزيره ما تعاني فيه او من
تعانيه مدينه درنه هو سوء اداره
الكارثه او الازمه
نحن شاهدنا حقيقه تحرك مجتمعي وشعبي على
مستوى ليبيا وهذا رائع جدا قرب الليبيين
ووحد الليبيين ولكن ما زلنا نعاني من سوء
اداره داخل مدينه درنه احيانا الان تصل
الى مدينه درنه كميات كبيره جدا من المواد
الغذائيه ومن الادويه وهناك سوء توزيع من
اسبابها طبعا انقطاع اوصال المدينه
والكباري بين المدينه ومدينه درنه موجوده
على ضفتي الوادي اللي جرفاته السيول هذه
مشكله ايضا عمليه الانقاذ
والانتشال بدات على التسير بوتيره احسن في
مدينه درنه ولكن ما زالت هناك تحتاج الى
اكثر دعم والى اكثر تطوير ونحن سنادينا في
السابق وما زلنا ننادي كنا نتمنى وندعو
الى جلب فرق متخصصه
في عمليه الكوارث لتقوم بعمليه الانقاذ
وعمليه الاشياء وعمليه الانتشار السيد
منصور حتى نفهم حقيقه الوضع في درنه الامم
المتحده تحديدا مكتب الاغاثه الاقليمي
يتكلم عن نقص حاد في الغذاء
ومسؤولون في ليبيا يتحدثون عن توفر للغذاء
وبالتالي كيف نفهم هاتين الصورتين
هذا سؤال هذا سؤال وجيه نعم عندما تغيب
الاداره الحقيقيه وخاصه في الازمات
والكوارث مهما كانت الكميه متوفره لا تصل
احيانا الى مستحقيه او تصل الى بعض
المستحقين ولا تصل الى طرف اخر انا على
تواصل مباشر مع اهلي ما زالت هناك بعض
المناطق تعاني من نقص حات في مياه الشرب
عاجزين عن توفير مياه الشرب عاجزين عن
توفير مواد الغذائيه ايضا بدات تظهر بعض
الظاهره البسيطه محاولات الاستغلال في
عمليات البيع لهذا نحن طلبنا وما زلنا
نطالب بايجاد لجنه في مدينه درنه لاداره
الازمه لجنه مدنيه من اهالي درنه داخل
مدينه درنه هي لتقوم بالاستلام بالاغاثه
سواء المحليه او الدوليه وتقوم هي
بتوزيعها بمشاركه الكشافه مثلا والهلال
الاحمر لان في بعض الناس موجوده في بيوتهم
وليس لديهم مواد غذائيه وليس لديهم مال
ماء ولا يخرجون الى الشارع او لا يذهبون
الى مواقع الاغاثه لكن لما تقوم بها اهل
درنه متمثله مثلا في الكشاف والهلال
الاحمر والجمعيات الخيريه وتشكيل لجنه
حقيقيه داخل مدينه درنه
ستصل الى كل المواطنين وسيتحقق الهدف
المرجو من الكميه الهائله حقيقه نحن نرى
من اهلنا واخواننا في الغرب الليبي
والجنوب ايضا كميات هائله على الصعيد على
الصعيد الاهلي ولا الصعيد الخيري والمدني
وما تقوم به الحكومه فهذه مشكله قائمه
ايضا سيدي الكريم لو تكرمت الان حقيقه
هناك وحده وهناك تقارب بين الشعب الليبي
ولحمه رائعه في مدينه درنه رغم الامها
ورغم فقدنا بلدات اكبادنا ورغم الانهيار
ورغم الكارثه لكن ايضا هناك اشكاليه
سياسيه ساضطر الحديث عنها انعكست سلبا على
مدينه درنه الانقسام السياسي ووجود
حكومتين انعكس سلبا على كارثه مدينه درنه
وانا ادعو مجلس النواب ومجلس الاعلى
الدوله نعم مجلس النواب الان رصد 10 مليار
حقيقه قبل العشر مليار الاولى بمجلس
النواب والمجلس على الدوله ان يتفقوا على
ايجاد حكومه واحده في
ابرز مراحل عمليات الانقاذ في مرحله ما
بعد الفيضانات نتعرف عليها في التقرير
التالي
في مرحله ما بعد الفيضانات المدمره فان
الخطوه الاولى وكما هي الحال بالتعامل مع
مختلف انواع الكوارث الطبيعيه تكون بالبحث
عن الناجين واجلاء العالقين والمحاصرين في
المناطق الخطره ويجب ان تضم فرق الانقاذ
افرادا المدربين ومجهزين بالمعدات اللازمه
مثل القوارب ومعدات الصوتي والكلاب
المدربه الخطوه الثانيه تكون بتقديم رعايه
الطبيه للمصابين وتقديم المساعدات
الاساسيه من ماكل ومشرب وماوى للمتضررين
والمشردين من الفيضانات ويجب الحذر خلال
هذه المرحله من حصول انزلاقات طينيه او
انجرافات للتربه في المناطق التي اجتاحتها
السيول تستمر هذه المرحله ما بين ثلاثه
ايام الى اسبوع وربما اكثر فالامر يعتمد
على حجم الفيضان ومساحه المناطق المتضرره
ومدى توفر الموارد البشريه والمعدات
اللازمه لفرق البحث والانقاذ وقدرتهم على
التنقل من منطقه لاخرى قياسا على مستوى
الضرر الذي لحق بالبنيه التحتيه المرحله
الثانيه تبدا بالتركيز على انتشال جثامين
الضحايا ودفنها خصوصا في ظل المخاطر
الناتجه عن تحلل الجثث وتلويثها لمصادر
المياه الامر الذي يزيد من خطر انتشار
الامراض المعديه مثل الكوليرا والتفويد
كما يجب البدء بمعالجه مظاهر التلوث
البيئي الذي تحدثه الفيضانات على المناطق
المتضرره لاسيما في حال تسببت بانهيار
شبكات الصرف الصحي وانتشار المستنقعات
وتجمعات المياه الملوثه والفضلات اذ يمكن
ان يتسبب التاخر في مواجهه ذلك بحصول
كارثه طبيه وانتشار الاوبئه وتعتمد مده
هذه المرحله على حجم الكارثه ونطاقها
الجغرافي والامكانات المتاحه لفرق
والانقاذ اما المرحله الثالثه مرحله
التعافي فتبدا بالعمل على تجهيز اماكن
اقامه دائمه لعائلات المنكوبه واعاده
تاهيل البنيه التحتيه من طرق وشبكات صرف
صحي وكهرباء وازاله الانقاض ومخلفات
الفيضان وتختتم هذه المرحله باعاده انشاء
السدود وتعزيز البنيه التحتيه المجاوره
للانهار والاوديه واتخاذ الاجراءات
اللازمه للحقول دون حصول كوارث مستقبليه
او التقليل من اثارها على الاقل
معنى من عمان الدكتور رضوان الوشاح استاذ
هندسه المياه والخبير الدولي في اداره
مخاطر الفيضانات اهلا بك دكتور رضوان في
هذه المرحله باعتقادك ما هي اول صعوبه يجب
تجاوزها للتقليل من مخاطر ما بعد هذه
الفيضانات
بدايه اسمحوا لي ان نعزي الشعب الليبي
الشقيق بهذه الفاجعه الكبرى
ونتمنى او نسال الله الرحمه للضحايا
والشفاء للمصابين
والمعافاه لنظام البيئي والنظام الهيدروجي
في هذه المنطقه اعتقد انه اهم المراحل
حاليا هو مرحله يعني
اللي هو تقدير الاضرار ومحاوله حصرها ورفع
الضرر المباشر ثم ننتقل بعد ذلك الى مرحله
التعافي وتاهيل الشبكات البنيه التحتيه
والسدود وشبكات المياه والصرف الصحي كما
تعلمون يعني فيضان الذي حصل في دارنا
كمثال من فيضانات الومضيه التي تحصل يهطل
هناك هطول مطري تم في هذه في هذا اليوم
يزيد عن 200 ملم
الدكتور
ما المقصود من فيضان ونمضي
فيضان والفيضان السريع الذي ياتي نتيجه
هطول مطري شديد في فتره قصيره يتجاوز هذا
الهطول معدل الهطول السنوي يعني معدل هطول
البطري في دارنا لا يزيد عن 200 ملي الذي
هطل في سنه هطل في يوم واحد في هذه
العاصفه عاصفه دانيال دانيه فهذا هذا
الفيضان له اثار مدمره لانه ياتي بصوره
سريعه ما بيكون عنا استعداد كافي عند
البنيه التحتيه وانظمه التصريف وفي
بالنسبه لموضوع
وادي درنه وادي درنا حسب الهطول المطر
المصرح به مساحه الحوض الذي يصب في وادي
درنه يزيد عن 555 كيلو متر مربع اذا حسبنا
وعملنا نموذج اعمل دراسي هيدولوجيه سريعه
باستخدام صور فضائيه وخرائط رقميه ونماذج
هيدروجين متقدمه وجدنا ان حجم الذي نتج عن
هذه العاصفه يزيد عن سبعين مليون متر مكعب
وبشده تصريف قصوى تزيد عن 1100 متر مكعب
في الثانيه اذا علمنا ان حجم السدود
الموجود سواء كان السد الكبير او السد لا
يتجاوز العشرين مليون فهناك عنا خمسين
مليون اضافيه هاي لا تستوعبها السدود بقول
نقطه اخرى مهمه هو ان عندما يتم انهيار
السد يولد موجه فيضان اضافيه بالاضافه الى
الموجه الاصلي الناتجه عن الهطول المطري
مما يلحق اثارا سلبيه على المنطقه تحت
السدود هذه نقطه مهمه دكتور رضوان
علميا لو كنا امام سدود او البعض يقول لم
تكن سدودا بل كانت اكثر منها مصدات مائيه
لو افترضنا انها سدود لو كنا امام سدود
حقيقيه يعني مهيئه ويجري صيانتها بشكل
دوري هل كانت ستقلل من حجم اندفاع هذا
الفيضان
ربما لكن احنا لا نعرف يعني اليه تصميم
هذه السدود كما علمت هذه السدود صممت في
اوائل السبعينات من القرن الماضي وبالتالي
كانت مبنيه على معلومات وبيانات مطريه
محدوده جدا حاله تصميمها وربما لم يخطب
قبال مصممها ان يهبطل هذا المطر او هذا
العاصف المطريه في هذه الفتره القصيره كما
حدث في الايام القليل الماضيه
يبدو ان السدود يعني هناك سد له جزئين
مهمات مهمين الجزء الاول هو
جسم السد وهو الحاجز المائي الذي يحجز
بحيره السبت خلفه والجزء الاخر هو مفيد
السد مفيض السد هو عباره عن قناه تصرف
يعني منشاه تصرف الفيضان الزائد عن حجم
السد في حاله ابتلاء السد الى الوديان
التي تقع تحته او افترضنا ان هذه المفايض
كانت سليمه وشغاله ومصارى بشكل جيد اعتقد
ان حجم الفيضان في هذه العاصفه يزيد عن
سعه هذه المفايض وبالتالي لم يتحقق الهدف
من منها لانه اكيد سعه هذه المفاوض كان
اقل من حجم الفيضان الاقصى الذي حصل في
خلال فتره الفيضان وبالتالي اعتقد انه كل
جسم السد اصبح مفيض وبالتالي احنا لما
يكون عنا جسم السد الميت طلعت فوق جسم
السد تسبب عمليه نحر لجسم السد خاصه ان
هذه السدود ركاميه يعني هذه السدود عباره
عن مناطق سدود حجريه في داخلها قلب طيله
او يعني قلب طيني يحجز الماء لما يجي المي
من فوقها بصير الجراف لهذه الجسم السد
وبالتالي يؤدي الى انهياره وهذا الانهيار
كارثي بمعنى الكلمه ويجب ان يكون هناك
يعني
كان الاولى ان يكون هناك مجموعه من السجود
في اعلى الحوض خاصه انه شريط الحوض هذا
يمتد لمسافه اكثر من 100 كيلو متر بعيدا
عن الساحل باتجاه الجنوب كالب الامكان
انشاء سدود تخفيفيه لاثار الفيضان وبنفس
الوقت تستخدم للحصاد المائي وتجميع المياه
لاغراض مختلفه هل جزء من ما زاد من حجم
هذه الكارثه هو ايضا البناء العمراني فيما
يمكن تسميته بالطريق الطبيعي لسريان هذه
هذا الوادي هل هذا هل هذا ممكن وارد نعم
نعم نعم هذا وارد احنا في عنا هناك حرم
للاوديه بنسميها مستوى الفيضان وهذا مستوى
الفيضان الوادي يحرر مجراه ولو بعد حين
نتيجه الجفاف وموجات الجفاف والتغير
ومناخي الذي حصل في بعض المناطق الناس
يقوموا باعمال الاعمار والبناء واحياء
البناء المزارع وبناء المنشات في السيل
الوادي وهذا يعطل من سعه الوادي التصريفيه
وبنفس الوقت يلحق اضرارا بهذه المنشات في
حاله الفيضانات في معظم الدول المتقدمه
هناك حرم محدد للوادي يحدد هذا الحرم بانه
هذا مستوى الفيضان الذي ياتي كل خمسين سنه
او كل 25 سنه او كل سنه وبالتالي عليك ان
تلتزم بكودات البناء بحيث ان يرتفع مستوى
بناءك على مستوى الفيضان التصميمي الذي
تضعه البلديه او السلطه المحليه طيب عند
حدوث كارثه بهذا الحجم وبهذه المعطيات
دكتور رضوان برايك ما التصور لما يكون
تسميه وبخارطه طريق للتعامل مع ما بعد هذه
الكارثه ما الذي يجب اولا
يجب طبعا بعد التعامل المباشره بانقاذ
الارواح والممتلكات والتعامل مع الضحايا
ومنع تلوث سواء كان تلوث البيئه وتلوث
المياه او الخدمات الصرف الصحي يجب ان يتم
اول شيء المعالجه هذه الامور لتفادي حدوثي
على سمح الله ثم بعد ذلك نبدا باعاده
تاهيل
المنشات والبنيه التحتيه وخاصه شبكات
المياه والصرف الصحي والخدمات الكهرباء
وغيرها والطرق طبعا الطرق جزء اساسي لاحظت
وانا من خلال استطلاعي لخريطه المنطقه
وخرائط الجويه ان هناك العديد من الطرق
التي تقطع هذا الوادي وبالتالي عندنا
انجرفت هذه الطرق اصبح هناك قدره على عدم
الوصول الى المناطق المنكوبه بسهوله
والوادي كما تعلمون طبوغرافيه صعبه جدا
يعني الارتفاع بالارتفاع بين ارضيه الوادي
والجبال المحيطه فيه تتجاوز الثلاثمائه
متر في بعض المناطق وهذه طبعا ميول واعره
والطموغرافيه صعبه ايجاد طرق بديله
وبالتالي اعتقد انه هناك تحدي كبير امام
فرق الانقاذ للوصول الى المناطق خاصه انه
هذا الوادي يقطع مدينه درنه شطرين وقد دمر
اكثر الدراسات تقول بالنماذج الهيدروجيه
تقول انه دمر ثلث مساحه من 25% الى 30% من
مساحه المدينه وهذا امر قطيع جدا من عمان
الدكتور الدكتور رضوان الوشاح استاذ هندسه
المياه والخبيره الدولي في اداره مخاطر
الفيضانات شكرا جزيلا لك
قال وزير البيئه في حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
الليبيه ابراهيم العربي منير ان السلطات
تتخوف من الاخطار البيئيه التي قد تنجم عن
السيول والتي قد تؤدي الى تلوث المياه
بالصرف الصحي
احتاج
الى قمه الحذر وقمه
يعني
المسؤوليه في تعامل مع مصادر التلوث من
المتمثله حقيقه في جثه ربما
غمرتها السيول واصبحت مدفونه في الطين
بصيره او باخرى وكذلك الحيوانات النافقه
واذا في اي مواد كيماويه موجوده بجرفها
السيل
[موسيقى]
الى المغرب وفيه تمكنت فرق الانقاذ من
اخراج امراه من تحت الانقاض بعد مرور سته
ايام على زلزال الذي ضرب وسط البلاد في
غضون ذلك تستمر عمليه فتح الطرق الجبليه
المؤديه الى القرى النائيه وسط مخاوف من
انهيارات صخريه جديده وكانت وزاره
الداخليه قد افادت بارتفاع عدد قتل
الزلزال الى
والمصابين الى 5674
افاد ديوان الملكيه المغربي انه تم تفعيل
المرحله الاولى من خطه طارئه لاواء متضرري
الزلزال وتشمل 50 الف مسكن انهارت كليا او
جزئيا في الاقاليم الخمسه المتضرره وفي
اجتماع عمل حكومي اشرف عليه العاهل
المغربي تم اقرار خطه ايواء مؤقت في هذه
المناطق تاخذ بعين الاعتبار تحديات كثيره
بينها الامطار وتراجع درجات الحراره كما
تقرر صرف مساعدات ماليه مباشره لتسريع
اعمال البناء او اعاده تاهيل المساكن التي
انهارت جزئيا وطالب العاهد المغربي
باستجابه سريعه وقويه تحترم كرامه الانسان
معنى من مراكش مراسله الجزيره ميساء
الفطناسي ومعها نتابع اهم مرصدته في
الساعات الماضيه في الاماكن التي تنقلت
فيها ميساء
نعم عبد القادر اليوم ومنذ صباح هذا اليوم
تنقلنا الى اكثر من منطقه واكثر من مدينه
هنا من المدن الواقعه على اطراف مدينه
مراكش حقيقه عيننا هناك ان اثار الزلزال
عندما نتحدث عن اثار صعبه
فاننا لا نعني فقط ربما القتلى رحمهم الله
او المصابين او المنازل المنهاره او
المتصدعه وانما نتحدث عن الوضعيه التي
يعيشها الناس الذين لم يصابوا باي مكروه
ربما ولكنهم اصبحوا مجبرين على عيش وضع
صعب بعد هذه الحادثه الاليمه وبعد هذا
الزلزال ربما نستطلع هنا في هذه الصوره
حال وواقع بعض الناس هنا الذين يجلسون على
حرف السور هنا في مدينه مراكش هذا السور
الذي يعني يقع
المدينه العتيقه او المدينه القديمه في
مراكش التي تضررت بفعل هذا الزلزال سكان
هذه المدينه كما نراهم يفترشون الارض في
في الليل في هذه في هذا الطقس الذي تنخفض
فيه درجات الحراره وخلال ساعات النهار
ايضا هم يقضون يومهم في درجات حراره
مرتفعه ايضا هذا الوضع يختلف من مدينه الى
اخرى ولكن هو يوصف اجمالا بانه معاناه
يعانيها السكان حيث في المدن الاخرى وجدنا
اورصدنا اوجه اخرى للمعاناه حيث كان الناس
يطالبون
بان تتوفر لهم خيام تاويهم من الظروف
الصعبه حيث هناك في الاطراف وفي المدن وفي
المناطق الريفيه
الطبيعه وعره صعب ان يفترش الناس الارض في
تلك المدينه وبالتالي
اقل مطالبهم هي خيام تاويهم الخيام موجوده
بعدد كبير عبد القادر ولكن لشده تاثير هذا
الزلزال ولشده اثاره القويه واثاره التي
طالت عديد المنازل وعديد المناطق وعديد
السكان فان الناس ما زالوا يطالبون بتوفير
عدد اكبر من هذه الخيام حتى يتمكنوا من
اتقاء الظروف الصعبه التي يعيشونها من
خلال بقائهم خارج منازلهم علما عبد القادر
بانه بعد حدوث
حالات
الارتداديه هذا اليوم وايضا غدا وايضا
الامس اصبح الناس يخاف اكثر اليوم واصبح
الناس اكثر رفضا للعوده الى منازلهم في
هذه الظروف لان هذه الظروف تجعلهم غير
امنين وخصوصا وان منازلهم التي من الممكن
ان يعودوا اليها اليوم هي
تعاني تصدعات وتشققات وبالتالي فهي اماكن
غير امنه وغير صالحه للعيش بوضعها الحالي
شكرا
معنا من قريه التملكت في اقليمي
تارودانتيري وهو مدير الاستراتيجيه في
الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيات الصليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر سيد كاربونتي بعد مرور سته
ايام خاصه في هذه المناطق النائيه والاكثر
تضررا ماذا عن اهم الحاجيات حسب تقييمكم
شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه هنالك الكثير من
الامور التي هنالك حاجه اليها الاكثر
الحاحا هي الغذاء والماء الذي تم اعطائه
من قبل سكان
المغرب والمغاربه بشكل عام
والان
يجب ان يتم حمايه الناس الذين فقدوا
منازلهم ويعيشون في العراء هنالك
البطانيات يتم اعطاؤها وايضا يجب
يجب ان يتم اعطائهم خيم ايضا بالتالي
وايضا يجب وضع خطط لبناء منازل لوائ هؤلاء
للاشخاص خصوصا مع اقترابي فصلي
فصل الشتاء وهذه هي الاحتياجات اهم
الاحتياجات التي هنالك التي يشهدها الناس
هناك ماذا عن متابعتكم للرعايه الصحيه
نعم ان الجانب الصحي سيكون مهما للغايه
هنالك بعض الاشخاص ساصيبوا بجراح واصابتها
هنالك يجب وهنالك حاجه الى الماء النظيف
لكي نمنع انتشار مثل الاوبئه او الامراض
المرتبطه بتناولي المياه غير النظيفه
بالتالي يجب ان نضمن ان بامكاني من الوصول
الى المياه الصالحه للشرب وايضا بعض الطرق
قد تكون قد اغلقت وبالتالي قد تعيق وصول
المساعدات وعلينا ان نهتم بهذا الامر ايضا
هنالك امر مهم وتقديم الدعم
المعنوي والنفسي والاجتماعي ان الناس
اصيبوا بالصدمه من جرائم الاحداث الاخيره
ماذا عن مساهمتكم انتم في الاتحاد الدوري
لجمعيه الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر
الدوليين
الهلال الاحمر المغربي كان له استجابه
سريعه منذ بعد ساعات الاولى
لزلزال
وكان هنالك في مدينه تملك حيث ان
هنالك يقوم الهلال الاحمر بتقديم الدعم
وتقديمي
المفارش ايضا هناك بالتالي كانوا في مقدمه
الاستجابه منذ الايام الاولى او الساعات
الاولى بعد الكارثه
هل لديكم برنامج خطه عمل سيد
هنالك عده مراحل لخطه العمل لدينا المرحله
مرحله الطوارئ التي
تتمثل بايجاد ناجين الان المرحله الثانيه
التي تمثل بتوفيره
ماوى والملابس
الدافئه والبطانيات التي تحمي الناس الذين
يفترشوا العراء وبعد ذلك المرحله الاخرى
بدانا بحديثي عن مساله عاده الاعمال قد
تكون الان قد يكون الان وقت مبكر للحديث
عن هذا الامر
شكرا لك من قريه تملك في اقليم تارودانت
بنوار مديره الاستراتيجيه في الاتحاد
الدولي لجمعيه الصليب الاحمر والهلال
الاحمر
في اخبارنا الاخرى قالت مصادر في ولايه
شمال كردفان السودانيه للجزيره ان قوات
الدعم السريع انتشرت منذ امس الاربعاء في
مدينه ام روابى ثاني اكبر مدن الولايه
واشرت المصادر الى ان الجيش السوداني كان
قد سيطر على المدينه يوم الثلاثاء الماضي
ثم انسحب منها امس نحو مدينه كوسي بولايه
النيل الابيض من جهتها قالت مصادر
بالحكومه للجزيره ان قوات الدعم السريع
نهبت عشرات السيارات واحتجزت بشكل غير
قانوني اكثر من 30 شخصا في مدينه ام روبا
اطلقت صراحه بعض منهم وفي العاصمه الخرطوم
افادت مصادر محليه للجزيره بان الجيش
السوداني قصف بالمدفعيه مواقع للدعم
السريع حول حيي جبرا وابو ادم جنوبي
المدينه
قال قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
دقلو في تسجيل صوتي منسوب اليه ان قوات
الدعم السريع ستبدا مشاورات لتشكيل ما
سماها سلطه مدنيه في المناطق الخاضعه
لسيطرتها ردا على ما وصفها بمحاوله قائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان ادعاء شرعيه
زائفه واضاف قائد الدعم السريع ان قيام
البرهان بتشكيل حكومه مقرها بورسودان يعني
الاتجاه نحو سيناريوهات حدثت في دول اخرى
بوجود طرفين يسيطران على مناطق مختلفه في
بلد واحد واكد حميثي ان قوات الدعم السريع
بامكانها دخول مدينه بورتسودان اذا ارادت
اعلن المكتب الاعلامي لرئيس البرلمان
اللبنانيين به بالريال توصل الى وقف
لاطلاق النار في مخيم عين الحلوه للاجئين
الفلسطينيين يبدا سريانه عند الساعه
السادسه مساء اليوم هذا ويسود الهدوء مخيم
عين الحلوه بعد الاشتباكات التي شهدها
الليله الماضيه واستمرت حتى الصباح اليوم
بين عناصر من حركه فتح ومجموعه تطلق على
نفسها اسم الشباب المسلم وقد ادت هذه
الاشتباكات الى مقتل تسعه اشخاص واصابه
عشرات ليرتفع عدد القتلى منذ بدايه
الاشتباكات في شهر يوليو الماضي الى تسعه
وعشرين والجرحى الى اكثر من 200
قالت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه في بيان انه
استمرارا لجهود المملكه وسلطنه عمان
للتوصل الى وقف اطلاق نار دائم وشامل في
اليمن والتوصل الى حل سياسي مستدام ومقبول
من كل الاطراف وجهت المملكه دعوه لوفد من
صنعاء لزياره السعوديه وذلك لاستكمال
اللقاءات والنقاشات بناء على المبادره
السعوديه المعلنه عام 2021 حسب بيان
الخارجيه السعوديه
معنا من الرياضه سالم اليامي المستشار
السابق في وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه سيد
سالم بدايه هل توفرت معلومات
اوفر عن هذه او هذا الاستمرار في التشاور
كما جاء في بيان الخارجيه السعوديه فيما
يتعلق بالازمه في اليمن
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم احييك اخي الكريم
احيي السيدات والساده المشاهدين واشكركم
لكريم الاستضافه انا اعت انما نحن بصدده
اليوم او ما نراه اليوم
هو ان هناك تقدم في ملف يسمى ملف مقاربه
الازمه اليمنيه
وتعرفون حفظكم الله ويعرف الساده والسيدات
المشاهدين ان الامور في اليمن يعني ليست
حاله حرب وليست حاله سلم كامله
والمفاوضات او المناقشات او اللقاءات التي
تمت في صنعاء في ابريل الماضي وكان هناك
وفدا سعوديا اجتمع معه يعني قيادات حوثيه
وكان هناك دائما رعايه او الوساطه
العمانيه
حل كثير من المعضلات في تقديرنا وانا
اعتقد اليوم ان هناك يعني امور بقيت سيصار
الى حلها ويعتقد في الحقيقه وهذا ما
يتناقل لكثير من المراقبين ان نحن على وشك
السماع او الارصات الى اعلان
باتفاق الاطراف اليمنيه الرئيسيه
الشرعيه والجانب الاخر على توقيع اتفاق
يعلن وقف اطلاق النار بشكل رسمي وبشكل تام
ويكون هذا الاتفاق يعني
باشراف الامم المتحده كما قالت المبادره
السعوديه 2021 وسيكون برعايه الدول
الاقليميه في مقدمتها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ما الذي قد يسهم في زياده
التفاؤل فيما يتعلق بامكانيه الوصول الى
هذا الهدف وهو وقف اطلاق نار دائم وشامل
في اليمن وكذلك التوصل الى حل سياسي
مستدام ومقبول في اليمن ما المؤشرات
الداعمه لهذا الهدف برايك
انا في تقديري ان هناك ضغوطات اقتصاديه
وانسانيه وامنيه وحتى يعني تتعلق بمعيشه
الناس وبحياتهم وباتصالهم وبالتنقل بين
المدن كل هذه الصعوبات في الحقيقه هي تزيد
يوم عن يوم هناك اخبار هناك نقص في المواد
الغذائيه هناك الغام تنتشر بين المدن
والمحافظات كل هذه الامور في الحقيقه هي
تجعل اليمن في حاله ما بين حالتين ليست
حاله حرب وليست حاله سلم الشيء الاخر انه
كان هناك بعض المطالب ربما ذات السقف
العالي من بعض الاطراف اليمنيه اعتقد انهم
تغلب على جزء كثير منها
واعتقد ان كل الاطراف اليمنيه اليوم هي
مقبله على او قابله
لان يكون هناك حل ينهي كل هذا الصراع
طيب ايضا ما بدا يمكن ان فعلا يحضر وفد من
صنعاء واستجابه لهذه الدعوه من قبل الرياض
هل من مؤشرات
يعني ماذا تقصد وفد من الجماعه الحوثيه ام
من الشرعيه يعني من الجماعه من الحوثيين
نعم اعتقد ان هناك وفد من الحوثيين سيكون
برفقه المفاوضي العمانيون وهناك اخبار
يعني وصلتنا او كمراقبين ومتابعين بطبيعه
الحال بان الوفد العماني التقى بقيادات
حوثيه في صنعاء هذا المساء واعتقد ان
الوفد مكون من اطراف حوثيه بالاضافه الى
الاشقاء من عمان ان لم يكونوا وصلوا الى
المملكه فهم في طريقهم الى المملكه شكرا
لك من الرياضه سالم اليامي المستشار
السابق في وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
شكرا قالت وزاره الخارجيه القطريه ان رئيس
الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري الشيخ محمد
بن عبد الرحمن ال سالي اكد في اتصال هاتفي
مع وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير
عبداللهيان التزام دوله قطر بدعم كل
الجهود الاقليميه والدوليه الراميه الى
تحقيق الامن والاستقرار في المنطقه بدورها
قالت الخارجيه الايرانيه ان عبد الله هيام
اكد خلال الاتصال استعداد بلاده التام
لاتمام تبادل السجناء مع الولايات المتحده
في الموعد المتفق عليه بواسطه قطر واعرب
الوزير الايراني عن شكره وتقديره للجهود
التي تبذلها قطر للافراج عن الاموال
الايرانيه في كوريا الجنوبيه فضلا عن
الافراج عن السجناء
حذر علي اكبر ولايه مستشار المرشد
الايراني للشؤون الدوليه في مقابله مع
الجزيره من زعزعه امن المنطقه بسبب ما
وصفها بادعاءات الامارات بشان الجزر
الثلاث والتي قال انها سببت مشاكل بين
جارين واشار ولايتي في مقابلته مع الجزيره
الى ان هذه الجزر جزء اصيل من اراضي ايران
التي لن تسمح لاي ادعاءات باطله بشان
الخليج الفارسي بان تتحقق عمليا حسب
تعبيره وقال مستشار المرشد الايراني
للشؤون الدوليه للجزيره ان بلاده لا تريد
نزاعا مع جيرانها ولكنها لا تتنازل عن
وحده اراضيها واكد مستشار المرشد انه لا
بديل لدول المنطقه عن انهاء الخلافات
مضيفا ان علاقه ايران بالسعوديه تشكل
مثالا على امكانيه تطوير العلاقه بدول
الجوار وقال مستشار المرشد الايراني
للشؤون الدوليه للجزيره طهران تنصح الغرب
بعدم تصعيد التوتر في منطقه حساسه وخطيره
كالخليج الفارسي وفق تعبيره
وصفت الخارجيه الايرانيه قرار الاتحاد
الاوروبي والثلاثي الاوروبي فرنسا
بريطانيا والمانيا عدم تنفيذ التزاماتهم
بالاتفاق النووي بعد مرور ثمان سنوات على
توقيعه بانه اجراء غير قانوني ويتعارض مع
التزاماتهم بموجب الاتفاق والقرار الدولي
2231 واضافت الخارجيه الايرانيه ان قرار
المجموعه الاوروبيه عدم الوفاء
بالتزاماتها ردا على خطوات ايران النوويه
يخلو تماما من اي منطق قانوني وشددت على
انها سترد بشكل مناسب وفي اطار حقوقها على
هذا العمل الاستفزازي وغير القانوني للدول
الاوروبيه حسب ما جاء في البيان
دان البرلمان الاوروبي رفض السلطات
التونسيه دخول وفد لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه
بالبرلمان الى تونس وطالب البرلمان
الاوروبي تونس بتفسير مفصل لما وصفه
بالسلوك غير المسبوق منذ ثوره عام 2011
بمنع وفد اوروبي من دخول البلاد وكان من
المقرر ان يزور تونس بدايه من اليوم
الخميس وفد برلماني اوروبي يضم اعضاء في
لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه لكنه ابلغ من
السلطات بانه غير مرغوب فيها وكان من
المقرر ان يلتقي الوفد الذي يتراسه عضو
البرلمان الاوروبي مايكل جاهلر بمنظمات
المجتمع المدني والنقابات العماليه وقاده
المعارضه وممثلي المؤسسات السياسيه والدول
الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي
تواصل سلطات الباكستانيه اغلاق معبر تورخم
الحدودي مع افغانستان لليوم العاشر على
التوالي وقالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجي
الباكستانيه ان حكومه بلادها ما زالت تدرس
امكانيه اعاده فتح المعبر لكن هناك قلقا
من سوء استخدام الجانب الافغاني للاتفاقيه
الخاصه بنقل البضائع التجاري الافغانيه
عبر الاراضي الباكستانيه
قال رئيس الوزراء الارميني نيكولا بشنيان
ان الوضع على الحدود مع اذربيجان متوتر
الى اقصى حد وفي باكو وصفت الخارجيه
الاذربيجانيه مركز القوات الارمينيه على
الحدود بانه تهديد لاستقرار المنطقه
نذور حرب اخرى بين ارمينيا واذربيجان تطل
هذه المره من ازمه المعابر وزاره الدفاع
الاذر بجانيه اتهمت الجيش الارميني
باستهداف مواقع لجنودها واكدت ان قواتها
ردت على ذلك الهجوم جاء الحادث بعد
التاكيد يا ريفان ان القوات الاذربيجانيه
تحركت نحو الحدود المشتركه واعلان باكو ان
تمركز القوات الارمينيه على الحدود يعد
تهديدا لاستقرار المنطقه
تاتي هذه التطورات على خلفيه موجه توتر
جديده بدات في يوليو تموز الماضي عندما
اغلقت اذربيجان ممر لاتشين الطريق الوحيد
الذي يربط ارمينيا باقليم كاراباخ ذي
الغالبيه الارمينيه وترتب على ذلك نقص
كبير في الامدادات واتهام ارمينيا لجارتها
اللدود بتجويع سكان الاقليم
لكن اذربيجان نفد تلك الاتهامات واعلنت ان
كاراباخ يمكن ان يتلقى كل المساعدات
اللازمه عبر طريق اقدام غير ان السلطات
الانفصاليه ترفض ذلك
ولان اي توتر في تلك المنطقه يمكن ان
يتطور الى جوله نزاع عسكري جديد فقد تكثفت
الوسطات لاحتواء الموقف والحيلوله دون
تحول ما بات يسمى ازمه انسانيه في كاراباخ
الى حرب اذ دعا الكرملين الطرفين الى ضبط
النفس والعمل في اطار الوثائق الثلاثيه
التي تم توقيعها منذ عامين مع الاخذ في
الاعتبار الحقائق الجديده التي ظهرت منذ
ذلك الحين بينما اعدت اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر قوافل مساعدات قالت انها
مستعده للتحرك عبر اي طريق ممكن لاغاثه
عشرات الاف المحتاجين للغذاء والدواء في
الاقليم
مخاطر التصعيد في جنوب القوقاز تتعدى
البلدين العدوين الى دول مجاوره قد تتعارض
مواقفها ومصالحها لكنها تلتقي عند الحاجه
الملحه لمعاهده سلام دائمه بين يريفان
وباكو واستكمال تنفيذ اتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار الموقع بينهما برعايه روسيه بعد حرب
عام 2020
الصحف والمواقع الاخباريه نشرت العديد من
المقالات والتقارير حول تداعيات الفيضانات
في ليبيا
والزلزال المدمر في المغرب نستعرض ابرز
تعليقاتها في التقرير التالي
قالت ان الكارثه التي اودت بحياه الالاف
في ليبيا مردها اكثر من 20 عاما من
الاهمال لم يخضع خلالها السدان القريبان
من مدينه درنا للصيانه رغم تحذيرات
الخبراء المتكرره
الصحيفه السندت في طرحها لتصريحات مسؤولين
ليبيين اشاروا ايضا الى تقرير صدر عن
ديوان المحاسبه الليبي في عام 2021 كشف عن
تبديل اكثر من مليار دولار كانت مخصصه
للصيانه السدين
صحيفه الجارديان علقت على الاصوات التي
تعالت في ليبيا للمطالبه بالتحقيق في
اسباب الاضرار الكارثيه للفيضانات في ظل
توقعات بارتفاع كبير في عدد الوفيات وذكرت
الصحيفه ان ندره المياه الصالحه للشرب
وقله اكياس حفظ الجثث من ابرز المشاكل
التي تواجه سكان المدينه المنكوبه وفرق
الانقاذ التي تمكنت من الوصول اليها
كتبت تحت عنوان ليبيا تكافح للتعامل مع
الاف الجثث مشيره الى ان الجهود في هذه
المرحله تتركز على تحديد هويه الالاف ممن
يعتبرون في عداد المفقودين ونقلت الصحيفه
عن احد المتطوعين قوله ان عمليات البحث عن
الجثث تزداد صعوبه بمرور الوقت والحاجه
اصبحت اكثر الحاحا لفرق متخصصه في ظل
المخاوف من كارثه صحيه بسبب الجثث العالقه
تحت الانقاض وفي عرض البحر
حول تداعيات الزلزال في المغرب ابرزت
صحيفه الاخبار المغربيه تاكيدات وزاره
التجهيز والماء في بيان انها قامت ابتداء
من ليله الثامن من سبتمبر بمراقبه جميع
سدود المملكه وتبين ان المنشات المائيه
سليمه ولم يلحقها اي ضرر نتيجه زلزال بما
في ذلك السدود في طور الانجاز بيان وزاره
وفق الصحيفه جاء بعد تداول بعض الاخبار
عبر الشبكات التواصل الاجتماعي حول تضرر
بعض الصدود باقليم الحوز
صحيفه الموندا الفرنسيه سلطت الضوء على
تضرر العديد من المعالم التاريخيه في
المغرب بفعل الزلزال المدمر وقالت ان 27
موقعا اثريا على الاقل تاثرت في المناطق
القريبه من مركز الهزه الارضيه العنيفه
اضافت الصحيفه ان ترميم المعالم الاثريه
في المغرب بعد الزلزال محل اهتمام من طرف
العديد من الخبراء الاجانب والمنظمات
الدوليه الناشطه في مجال حمايه الاثار
قباحت مغربي تزيد الدراسات والوثائق
المتوفره الخاصه بالمعالم المتضرره من
احتمالات انجاح عمليات الترميم
[موسيقى]
متواصله للفيضانات في ليبيا والزلزال وقد
بلغ يومه السادس في المغرب اذا هذه
التغطيه متواصله ويستمر معكم فيها الزميل
زين العابدين توفيق